hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are back to review
arc iv
of this black clover business being the
eye of the midnight sun and i suppose it
really was something of a direct sequel
to the royal capital arc that expands on
our big group of bad dudes and
dudettes and in a way that was really
great but i have a lot more questions
than i had before the first of which is
will you subscribe to the new world
review and like this video in order to
let me know if you
want more black clover stuff i try not
to read the comments of these videos due
to fear of spoilers so that's how we
need to run this operation now getting
into it as for the premise of the ark
the clover kingdom is still reeling from
the recent assault on the capital
questions are being asked traitors are
being posited and amongst all of this
astor is taking some well-earned time
off which inevitably leads to some time
on because manga gonna manga as we delve
deeper into the midnight sun group than
i thought we would anytime soon and
probably my favorite thing about the ark
is just how
damn smoothly it flows its events feel
very natural and we take a bit more time
to let things unfold i mean for example
in the previous two arcs we were very
suddenly thrown into things you know
asked to get stumped with a mission then
bam we are straight into action whereas
with this one tabitha elected to do the
opposite and astor was told to do
nothing which was a nice touch to begin
leading with a comedic blind date sort
of scenario
which led into meeting all of the kids
as well as gauche which then leads into
action to save the kids which then leads
into utter magical madness it's very
simple but the events of this arc flow
very well into one another nothing is
jarring and it just keeps building and
building to the point where we have what
is turned out to be the most
intense blind state of all time and i
think what greatly helps with that is
that the main group of villains were
established in the previous arc so we
didn't have to go through the basic
introductory phase and i must say
i do like the midnight sun guys a lot
more than i did previously although
maybe it's just these more specific
members and i guess licks needs to be
brought up pretty damn immediately
because he is kind of
single-handedly responsible for my
renewed interest in the group at first
he gives me a super strong griffith from
berserk sort of vibe you know this all
ornately beautiful
existence with overwhelmingly dark
intentions like her perversion of
aesthetic that impression changed pretty
rapidly though when valtos got hurt and
licht made this absolutely terrifying
face that broke his delightful facade
but showing that he legitimately cares
for his fellow
and i don't really know what to call
them cultist his fellow cultists
question mark doesn't matter though
because the camaraderie is there which
seems to be a running theme with the
midnight sun even right at the beginning
of the arc the two captured members say
something along the lines of when all
others betrayed us the master did
not we could never repay that with
betrayal and licks later expands on this
by referring to his group as the targets
of jealousy fear discrimination
persecution and theft which i don't know
does that essentially just make them
another incarnation of the black bulls
except that the primary difference would
be that the bulls choose to defy
societal standards whilst working within
the system whilst the eye of the
midnight sun wants to destroy the system
and replace it with their own more
subjectively equal system i shall call
it
magical socialism at least that's the
vibe i got and i do think that licht is
quite a good figurehead of that
although when it comes to their
technical goal i'm still kind of less
than convinced because if i understand
correctly what they need is the magic
rocks to put into a bigger magic rock
which will then turn everyone into super
mages which is a bit meh because i feel
like it means we're going to spend a lot
of time focused on finding objects that
will all inevitably come together in
favor of the antagonist anyways i don't
know just just do it with that said it
really doesn't matter too much though
because to say i'm hugely invested in
the plot of black clover right now would
be
an outright lie it's all about the
characters for me and speaking of
this arc only reinforced my initial
impression of the army as by far the
greatest character in the series this
man
is everything he is a dark magic sword
wielding badass with a phenomenal aspect
of humor in fact his comedy is what
sells me on him the most like i remember
there was this particular moment where
he was teaching astro about key which is
well that's something else but when
astor used it for the first time yami
was just all like
you actually managed to do it creepy get
away from me
and i obviously can't do the line
justice but i think every second thing
yami said had me laughing in addition to
that he also has what i consider to be
the best drawn action scenes in the
series thus far i love that in many
panels tabita elects to hide a lot of
yami's face
sometimes showing just a single eye it
takes away a lot of his humanity and
really makes him seem like a monster in
the dark and what's even cooler is that
xiaomi is directly equated to the power
of the wizard gang
not only by valtos but also licht who
states that the army was the second
person with the power to defeat him
which i find strange given that the end
of the arc introduces us to three other
characters whom licked claims are far
superior to him in combat but
it doesn't matter what matters is yami a
very obvious and appropriate name for a
dark magic user of course but yami also
introduces us to a very important
i think new concept being key which i am
led to believe is a completely separate
system to mana and in fact i think this
was even hinted at during the last arc
in retrospect yuna was almost certainly
using ki when all of his senses were
taken away by the
the witch woman right in terms of what
key actually is though well the one
piece fan within me just wants to call
it observation hockey it's the same sort
of effect only asta learnt at roughly
600 chapters before luffy did and
honestly i'm not quite sure how to feel
about it i do like it but i also feel
like we haven't quite gotten the hang of
basic magic use yet so introducing a new
system on top of that is
well it's very fast moving but as for
magic it continues to be expanded upon
and this arc highlights the importance
of matchups i quite like the idea that
certain types of magic are hard counted
by others in this kind of scissors paper
rock style system which is what we call
it in australia we don't do this rock
paper scissors nonsense and it was
really cool to see army's dark magic
interact with licks light magic and
oh god act like just means light in
german doesn't it i can't
believe it took me until right now this
moment mid-recording to notice that hm
so basically in this arc we had two
people fighting whose names were
literally light
and dark fantastic but it was nice to
see a sort of tired match up light and
dark countering each other in equal
measure coming equipped with their
inherent and polar opposite advantages
and disadvantages
magic is also getting a bit weird though
because there was a part of this arc
where the idea of transferring magical
power was very
very casually introduced and apparently
absolutely everyone can do it including
young children
which i don't know surely from here on
out the answer to every non-aster
related problem becomes if you're
injured then immediately follow your
magic into the nearest mage and turn
them into a supermage which
i guess is a good segue into gauche our
arc specific black bull focus
member guy who is the exact opposite of
the more carefree nature we've seen
expressed in the other members thus far
which is good that's very good actually
it's always nice to see a different
exploration although the sister complex
is pretty
heavy for me then again i don't have
siblings so i don't quite get that bond
but it does tend to border on the
the creepier side for me though however
i do find it quite interesting that the
other key player in this story threat is
a nun or sister
if you will so this man is just
surrounded by that sister complex at
every turn and just very briefly god
that nun was incredible as soon as i saw
those scars i knew she was serious
business and there was a great fun
generational aspect to her as well
having been fuego leon's teacher and all
but
back to gauche though his story was
quite satisfying mostly because his
change of heart came directly from his
sister like the last thing i wanted was
another situation where astor said a
sentence which instantly changed a core
personal flaw like what appeared to
happen with luck so it was great to see
that gauche's personal growth came from
the one person in the world that he
would
actually listen to and what's even
better is that after that we saw a great
example of a magic knight
leveling up in real time because a new
spell appeared in gosha's grimoire after
he had the realization of working with
others that sort of stuff is really
satisfying to me
and astor had a moment like that as well
actually there was this part where he
quoted fuego leon by stating that a
magic knight should always keep a cool
head and even though that didn't lead to
like a new spell
or anything it shows me that astor has
grown and that he is now much more
prepared to handle the world than he was
during the last arc so good
on him however when it comes to astor
there is something that i
quite profoundly hate which is his
ever-growing harem it's getting a bit
ridiculous now when it was noel a mimosa
well that was one thing but we now have
two other
females head over heels in love laster
being rebecca and marie the latter of
which
is very young and i'd even throw sally
in as well as someone who's certainly
obsessed with asda albeit on a very
different level and it just kind of
sucks it's by far the worst part of the
series and i feel like it's only going
to get worse
i mean when we have stuff like noel
dressing up as a maid just to spy on
astor's alleged and non-existent love
life that's very much where i check out
of the story for a while with astor
though something i do very much like
about him is how easy it is to have him
involved in conflicts that he really
should not be a part of but he has this
perfect excuse with anti-magic because
that's such a rare utility that can be
used to great effect whereas i feel like
in many other series it can be quite a
struggle to bring the protagonist into
battles like this because they really
have no business being there oh and we
also found
out asta's official rank which as of
right now is junior magic knight
third class although i maintain he's
much closer to an intermediate rank
about where leopold is but we cannot
conflate power with bureaucracy these
ranks are obviously more achievement
based than they are power based over
there it is good to have some sort of
solid footing for him though because now
it's only like what 17 or 18 more levels
to go until we reach the status of
wizard king oh and something i haven't
spoken about yet licht seems to be quite
intimately familiar with asta's grimoire
and his abilities his swords even have
names actually the demon slayer and the
demon dweller
sounds quite cool really although in the
end it turns out that they once belonged
to the ever mysterious
master because while licht is the leader
there exists an even greater master who
is maybe the actual leader i don't know
fun i'm looking forward to exploring
that a bit more maybe and as for going
into things a bit more these midnight
sun reinforcement
trio guys are quite fascinating aren't
they especially the one
named farna which just happens to be the
exact same name of mars childhood friend
and so there's absolutely no way that
they aren't the same person right i
would flip
every table within a 100 meter radius if
tarbata just used the exact same name
twice and
pretty much the exact same design for no
good reason and fauna would fit in quite
rightly with this group's theme
assumedly having been cast aside and
devalued by her own kingdom the evil
diamond kingdom damn diamonds so that
sounds like more good stock for some fun
personal conflict in the future with mr
diamond himself
but more importantly she has an adorable
salamander another spirit of the four
great attributes quite a terrifying
little pet really the other guy of
interest is mr copy magic which
i honestly don't remember if his name
was stated if it was sorry i just don't
remember
vana and the other guy's names were but
i like his design quite a bit though
it's sleek unique but tarbata has made
him well like
not overly pretty if that makes sense
which is unique because tarbeta does
have a habit of creating these very
pretty characters but mr copy man here
has this almost
underwhelmingly plain face which oddly
enough does make him stand apart in this
series of very well sculpted specimens
and at the end of the arc he is at the
center of all of the intrigue where it
is shockingly revealed
that he was one of the people present in
the captain's meeting as for which one
he was well
tabitha kind of breaks the fourth wall
there and even has the character
straight
so which one was me and at this stage
honestly i don't know the obvious guess
is the golden dawn leader because i
don't understand how
anybody anywhere at any time can trust
that face but at the same time
is that too obvious this guy is so damn
suspicious that he's making me second
guess
my own suspicion at the same time though
i really don't know who else it would be
maybe
one of the miscellaneous captains that
we really haven't gotten to know yet but
would that be underwhelming i don't know
though i've still got my eye on you
william
van gentz if that is indeed your real
name and if it is that's also highly
suspicious because vangen
sounds like vengeance and basically
every midnight suncultist in the series
seems to be driven by
vengeance but all in all another solid
arc for black clover this is usually the
point where i would have dropped a
series if i was feeling less than great
and whilst it does have a few flaws this
series continues to hold my interest
though with very strong characters and i
look forward to seeing where we end up
next but that pretty much does it for
this blind review of the eye of the
midnight sun arc and what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you are keen for
some more black clover content then
please to go and check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for very maybe black clover
goodness delivered straight into your
youtube feed but for now this has been
the new world review
and i'll see you next time